-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Michael Shannon.
And, Michael,
this is very exciting --
your brother and your mother
are here in the audience
with us tonight.
-Oh, they are?
-Yeah.
-What?
Shut the front door.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-There they are,
right over there.
-What?
Oh, my God!
Look at that.
There's Geraldine
and there's David.
-Geraldine and David.
And David--
David's 40th birthday today.
-Yeah, my little brother,
he's 40 years old today.
-Yeah, that's great.
-January 3rd.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Congratulations, Dave.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Can we do anything for him?
-What would you like to do?
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Do you want to --
You want to come --
Why don't you come up?
-No.
-Oh, come on!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Come on, come up, come up.
Come on, man.
Get on up here.
[ Whistling ]
Yeah, man.
Oh, man.
Alright.
Happy Birthday, bro.
-Hey. Thanks, Mike.
-Happy Birthday.
-Hey. Thanks.
-Have a seat.
-Wow. Okay.
-Now we should stress
if it was your mom's birthday,
you would've brought her up?
-No. Still him.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
-Alright, so, Dave, I did know
this was going to happen...
-Oh!
-Oh, gosh.
-...we met each other backstage
-We did.
-and I think I prayed it --
I played it -- excuse me --
pretty cool.
-Yeah, you did.
-So, hey, you guys,
this is Dave's birthday.
Alright, you want to blow
that out for us real quick?
-Yeah.
-No, we're not going
to do the song.
-Yeah, no singing.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
-[ Blows ]
-Nice!
-Alright, there we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
-Alright, so, Dave,
we mentioned --
we mentioned Kentucky.
-Yeah.
-That's where you guys grew up
and you still live there.
What was it like
growing up together?
Did you guys get along as kids?
-I think so.
[ Laughter ]
As far as I can remember.
-We used to play
this game called Bonkers.
-Yeah.
-Remember this game?
-I remember Bonkers, yes.
-So we had --
-Unfortunately.
-Yeah. It was a hallway
[ Laughter ]
where all the bedroom --
there were like
three bedroom doors.
And what you'd have to do is
you'd have to --
Because we have two sisters,
so there were four of us.
So, one of us would be stationed
in each of the doors
and then one of us would have
to run down the hall.
-I got to be the runner.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. You were
usually the runner
because you were the little one.
-Right.
-And so, everybody
in the doorway had a pillow
and you had to try
and run down the hall
without getting
completely creamed
-Beat the hell out of me.
[ Laughter ]
-by a pillow.
-I mean cream me, you know.
-Bonkers is an excellent name
for that game.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, Bonkers, yeah.
-Obviously, your brother is
an accomplished bongo player.
-Right.
-Did you have
a musical upbringing?
Did you play anything?
-Drums.
-I grew up playing -- I actually
started playing the cello
and then now, I play the drums.
-Alright, still play the drums.
-Still play the drums.
-Alright. There you go.
Did you guys --
Were you the kind of family --
Did you take a lot of road trips
as kids?
[ Laughter ]
-No. Where did we go?
-No.
-We'd go to the Natural Bridge
every once in a while.
-Yeah.
-What's the Natural Bridge?
-Oh, it's beautiful.
It's in Kentucky.
It's in the Red River Gorge.
-Red River Gorge.
Yeah.
-It's a natural bridge that,
I guess, was just made by time.
[ Laughter ]
Eroding rocks.
-Yeah.
-Very well named.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a rock.
-It's not false advertising.
[ Laughter ]
-When you get there,
you're not like,
"This isn't natural."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, it's Styrofoam.
They painted it."
So, wait, now, Dave,
growing up with Michael,
did you have any sense that
his path would be into acting?
-I mean, yeah, I guess so.
I guess you could say that,
yeah.
I mean, I always knew there was
something special about him.
-Oh, that's very sweet, yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
[ Awws ]
-What's your least favorite
of his movies?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-There you go.
-"8 Mile."
-Oh, there you go. Interesting.
[ Laughter ]
-"8 Mile."
-Don't hear that very often.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yep.
-I know this T-shirt
looks very threatening,
but we got this at a a duckpin
bowling place in Cincinnati.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Alright, got it.
-Because I was just shooting
something in Cincinnati
and they came up to visit me
one weekend
and this is --
-Pins Mechanical Co.
-Cincinnati.
-Actually, that's very helpful
because it is very menacing
and it's kind of the opposite,
which is it's bowling,
but with the tiny pins.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, with the tiny pins.
-Yeah.
-And it's not about force.
It's about finesse.
[ Laughter ]
Because Mom won.
-Yeah, she won.
We played her.
-Can't beat her.
-Geraldine, were you surprised
you won bowling,
or did you expect it?
-I expected it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Alright, so, Michael, you know,
I don't want to --
I know you're the guest
on the show,
but we're celebrating
your brother,
so, why don't you tell us
what's your favorite thing
about your brother Dave here
on his 40th birthday?
-Oh, man.
[ Laughter ]
-My brother's one of the
toughest people I know.
-Oh, right?
-Yeah.
-Cool.
-He's been through a lot
and he's still here
to tell the tale, so.
-That's right.
-Yep.
-Yep!
-That's my brother.
-Well...
[ Cheering and applause ]
...thank you very much
for being here.
Thank you for being
our second guest of 2023.
-Right, yeah.
-You guys, give it up
for the Shannon Brothers!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
The finale of "George & Tammy"
airs January 8th on Showtime.
We'll be right back
with Danielle Brooks.
Happy birthday, Dave.